[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine
Mandarinen Quarktorte die wird sehr
leichte Magen liegen und ist auch sehr
sehr leicht in der Zubereitung ich
starte jetzt mit meinem berühmten
blitzboden ich liebe den wenn es schnell
gehen muss und dafür nehme ich jetzt die
Küchenmaschine ihr könnt auch euer
Handrührgerät verwenden aber die
Küchenmaschine schlägt natürlich alles
noch ein bisschen fluffiger auf und dann
habt ihr einen fluffigeren und etwas
höheren Boden hier habe ich jetzt die
Eier reingegeben da kommt jetzt noch
Zucker mit dazu ich schreibe euch
übrigens wie immer alle ganz genauen
Mengenangaben hier unten in der
Videobeschreibung auf damit dieses Video
nicht so lange hat mich und so
langweilig wird aber ich gestalte die
Videos immer eben so wie ich glaube dass
sie mir auch als Zuschauer am besten
gefallen würden aber schreibt mir gerne
immer euer Feedback in die Kommentare
jetzt gebe ich dir auch schon direkt
Vanilleextrakt mit dazu und dann wird
das bei hoher Geschwindigkeit so 23
Minuten lang richtig schön dick cremig
geschlagen
[Musik]
also bei mir war es jetzt noch
eineinhalb Minuten schon fertig ich
vergesse halt auch immer dass die
Maschine ultra-leistungsstark ist und
ich dadurch immer eigentlich nur die
Hälfte an Zeit brauche die ich euch
vorgebe falls ihr aber ein Handrührgerät
verwendet dann haltet euch so an drei
bis vier Minuten guck mal so muss die
Masse aussehen also richtig schön
fluffig und hell da gebe ich jetzt Öl
mit dazu ich nehme immer das Öl da das
Öl
ich nehme immer das Öl was ich gerade da
habe also das habe ich gerade Rapsöl da
könnt auch Sonnenblumenöl nehmen
Olivenöl jetzt nicht so geil glaube ich
hier geschmacklich was gebe ich jetzt
einfach mit dazu rühre ganz kurz alles
noch mal unter also wirklich nur für ein
paar Sekunden und dann könnt ihr
parallel hier schon mal Backpulver und
Mehl einfach schon mal miteinander
verrühren und dann hin zu sieben dann
ist die Masse auch schon fertig
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier meine 24 cm
Springform und ich habe kein Backpapier
zu Hause ehrlich habe nur so ein kleines
Fitzelchen aber es ist gar nicht schlimm
denn dadurch dass ich jetzt in meinem
Teig auch ein bisschen Fett habe und die
Springform ja sowieso eine gute
Beschichtung hat und antihaft ist kann
ich das jetzt einfach einfüllen dann
kann ich das gleich einfach wirklich
super easy lösen alles unglaublich ich
habe kein Backpapier zu Hause gibt's
doch gar nicht so Streiche sondern ein
bisschen glatt dann verrate ich euch
auch schon mal die Backzeit und zwar
habe ich den Ofen vorgeheizt auf 180
Grad Ober- und Unterhitze ganz wichtig
dass du den auch wirklich immer lange
genug vorher vorheizt damit der wirklich
diese Schockstarre bekommt und dann in
aller Ruhe backen kann so einmal schön
verstreichen und dann ist er auch
eigentlich schon nach 14 bis 15 Minuten
garen danach lasse ich ihn vollständig
auskühlen aber benutzen die Zwischenzeit
und machen die leckere Quarkcreme
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so wir benötigen wieder ein paar
einfache Zutaten die ihr eigentlich
überall bekommt und zwar Schlagsahne am
besten sollten die Zutaten jetzt sehr
sehr kalt sein ich mache es aber anders
damit ich gleich keine Sauerei habe gebe
ich jetzt erstmal Mascarpone in meine
Rührschüssel das wird eine Quarkcreme wo
ich auch ein bisschen Mascarpone Anteil
habe einfach damit die Creme schön fest
wird ihr wisst ja Quark ist immer so ein
bisschen wabbeliger Mascarpone hilft
einfach beim stabilisieren und schmeckt
auch noch schön neutral also perfekt
in der Schüssel bzw sollte eigentlich
reinplappen so und da kann ich dann
schon direkt Zucker mit dazu geben für
die süße für den Geschmack habe ich mir
überlegt Vanille und Zitronenschalen
Abrieb ist immer eine schöne Kombination
also einfach ein bisschen rein bei der
Zitrone drauf achten dass sie die Schale
mit verzehren könnt also am besten eine
Bio Zitrone nehmen und bitte auf gar
keinen Fall unter der gelben Schale die
weißt du noch mit reiben sonst ist die
ganze Creme total Mütter also ihr müsst
wirklich immer wieder gucken ich weiß
nicht ob man es schon sieht aber ich
schreibe mal ein bisschen genau das hier
darf man nicht mehr reiben weil sonst
wird es total bitter und dann denkt man
sich ja super gekehrter volle Rezept für
die Creme entwickelt aber eins ist super
lecker wenn ihr wirklich nur die gelbe
Schale verwendet da reicht jetzt auch
nur die halbe Zitrone es muss jetzt
nicht zu zitronig werden wir gleich noch
die schöne Fruchtanlage das zeige ich
euch dann im Anschluss so da gebe ich
jetzt auch schon Sahne mit dazu ganz
langsam und kann schon mal ein bisschen
verrühren aber so dass ich das erst
verbindet und dann könnt ihr immer mehr
Sahne dazugeben bis in der homogene
Masse erhaltet
[Musik]
also sobald gemerkt dass die Creme ein
bisschen fester wird und vor allem auch
der Schneebesen musste einzeichnet in
die Creme ist es soweit und ihr könnt
Sahne fester zu geben das sorgt einfach
noch mal für die Stabilität und ganz zum
Schluss kommt Magerquark dazu und den
rührt ihr wirklich nur ganz kurz unter
aber sonst wird er zu flüssig deswegen
gebe ich den hier auch ganz zum Schluss
mit rein alles schön ausschaben und
Nichts verschwinden hier und dann wie
gesagt nur noch 45 Sekunden lang
einrühren die Creme werde ich in der
Zwischenzeit kühl stellen mein Ofen hat
gerade gepiept und der Boden ist fertig
der muss jetzt erstmal auskühlen und die
Creme kommt in der Zwischenzeit dann in
den Kühlschrank
[Musik]
für unsere fruchteinlage brauchen wir
einen Saft eurer Wahl also das was sie
am liebsten mögt ich habe hier einfach
Multivitaminsaft genommen und nehme
jetzt hier für mein Konstrukt so nenne
ich mal damit wir die fruchteinlage
gleich einfrieren können nämlich hier
einfach einen cakeboard da könnt ihr
einfach irgendein flachen Gegenstand
nehmen und dann habe ich hier noch
meinen Tortenring den benutze ich ja
gleich sowieso noch zum Schichten der
Torte dann habe ich hier einfach ein
bisschen Frischhaltefolie und ich nehme
da immer gerne zwei nebeneinander damit
mir dann die Fruchtanlage gleich auch
nicht ausläuft wichtig ist das ja auch
eine schöne gerade Oberfläche habt damit
ihr eben ja kein Saft irgendwie in einem
Tiefkühlschrank habt oder das irgendwie
ausläuft so das könnt ihr dann hier
einfach hinlegen die Seiten schön
hochziehen wie gesagt als Auslaufschutz
so ein bisschen
und dann reicht das eigentlich auch mit
unserer Vorbereitung also so ist es
eigentlich perfekt und dann habe ich
hier wie gesagt einfach nur Saft und
Argentine das ist pflanzliches
Geliermittel also veganische
Geliermittel quasi wird aus eigen
gewonnen schmeckt aber überhaupt nach
gar nichts also da brauchte ich
überhaupt keine Sorgen machen ich werde
das jetzt hier einfach erstmal verrühren
dann den Herd einschalten und dann zwei
Minuten sprudelt kochen lassen
[Musik]
die zwei Minuten sind rum ich nehme
einmal die Pfanne vom Herd und jetzt am
besten noch mal so fünf sechs sieben
Minuten ausdampfen lassen und dann fülle
ich das hier rein wie gesagt ich habe ja
Platz im Tiefkühlschrank da braucht es
nur 10 Minuten aber ihr könnt auch ganz
normal den Kühlschrank verwenden dann
wird es vielleicht 20 25 oder maximal 30
Minuten je nachdem wie kalt euer
Kühlschrank eingestellt ist aber ich
weiß dass die meisten noch kein Platz
haben im Tiefkühlschrank ist auch mein
tägliches struggle aber ich habe
aufgeräumt und da ging das bei mir wie
gesagt und anschließend machen wir
weiter und stellen die ganze Torte
zusammen
der spaßigste Teil beginnt okay das
Backen hat auch Spaß gemacht aber jetzt
wird es richtig cool denn wir stellen
alles zusammen ich habe mir jetzt eine
hübsche Tortenplatte ausgesucht mal
gucken ob sich das beißt oder nicht aber
ich glaube es passt ganz gut ich hätte
auch ein bisschen Unterstützung hier
meine Kamera Frau Jasmin und wir gucken
einfach mal ich glaube es wird ganz gut
passen aber ich leg sowieso ein
cakeboard unten drunter damit ich
notfalls auch einfacher noch mal
umstülpen kann und falls ihr kein Platz
im Kühlschrank habt ist so ein cakeboard
auch immer gut weil dann könnt ihr das
ganz einfach immer umdisponieren ohne
Stress zu haben ohne die Riesen
tortenplätze noch dabei zu haben so der
Boden ist jetzt einmal drauf und jetzt
brauchen wir eigentlich noch mal unseren
Tortenring ich habe natürlich mehrere
Tortenringe da aber wenn ihr jetzt nur
ein zuhause habt dass er überhaupt nicht
schlimm ist nehmt ihr einfach die
fruchteinlage raus
lass die einfach hier auf der Folie aber
da könnte ich jetzt auch noch mal mit
dem Tortenring Löser an damit ich mir
die Fruchtanlage nicht rausreißen
ah geht's ja perfekt und dann nehmen wir
uns so dann nehmen wir uns eigentlich
nur den Tortenring ich mache den jetzt
auch gar nicht sauber das macht
überhaupt nichts macht ihn einfach ein
bisschen größer die Torte ist ja 24 cm
groß also den Tortenring einmal um den
Boden legen hat den Vorteil dass ihr das
jetzt hier auch noch mal schön eng dran
machen könnt was habe ich jetzt für ein
Durchmesser
23,5 das heißt der Boden wird nach dem
Backen auch noch so ein bisschen leicht
zusammenschrumpfen das ist ganz normal
so und jetzt einfach die Creme zur
Hälfte hier drin verteilen glatt
verstreichen dann kommt unsere leckere
fruchteinlage oben drauf und dann kommt
die restliche Creme dazu das ganze glatt
verstreichen und dann schließen wir
miteinander reden ab ihr könnt jetzt
noch mal also ich mache auch oft ohne
Tortenplatte aber damit es ein bisschen
einfacher geht könnt ihr jetzt auch noch
meine Tortenplatte die drehbar ist unten
drunter tun dann habt ihr ein bisschen
einfacher
[Musik]
für den Abschluss brauchen wir natürlich
Mandarinen aus der Dose und da könnt ihr
den Saft auf jeden Fall einmal
abschöpfen ich habe jetzt hier mein Saft
abgewogen 250 Gramm wert das jetzt noch
mal mit meinem Multivitaminsaft einfach
auffüllen auf 300 Gramm auf die müssen
wir nämlich auf jeden Fall kommen
perfekt so und außerdem schönere Farbe
so und das werde ich gleich wieder
zusammen mit Argentine das was wir
gerade auch schon hatten einmal
aufkochen das Netz ist nur das
Verhältnis ein bisschen anders die
Fruchtanlage musste fester sein und dass
sie muss jetzt nicht ganz so fest sein
wie gesagt ich schreibe euch alles ganz
genau unten in die Video Beschreibung
was ich jetzt aber auch schon mal
vorbereitet sind die Mandarin ich mag es
halt wenn die ein bisschen kleiner sind
dann kann man später die Torte auch ein
bisschen besser durchschneiden also
einfach mit dem Messer hier so ein paar
Mal entlang gehen dann sind die halbiert
oder sogar auch gedreht und dadurch dass
wir jetzt auch den süßen Saft haben
brauchen wir gar keinen Zucker mehr
so und jetzt geht's wieder an den Herd
wieder kurz verrückt das ist klümchen
frei ist und dann zwei Minuten lang
sprudeln kochen lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe hier den Guss jetzt auch noch
mal 12 13 Minuten lang auskühlen lassen
denn jetzt kommt der wirklich der warme
Guss auf die Sahne Quarkcreme und das
ist wirklich ein bisschen heikel da
solltet ihr auf jeden Fall darauf achten
dass wenn ihr anfasst das ist eigentlich
nur noch ganz leicht lauwarm ist sollte
jetzt natürlich nicht fest werden aber
das wird es auch nicht also das ist
eigentlich ein ganz entspannter groß
muss ich sagen sehe ich aber erstmal
kurz zur Seite ich wollte euch nämlich
noch einen Tipp geben für die Mandarinen
da könnt ihr noch mal mit einem
geschirrtor mit dem Küchentuch könntet
ihr auch machen wenn sauber ist einfach
noch mal drüber gehen und den Saft
aufsaugen weil das kontraproduktiv ist
wenn der Saft jetzt auch noch mal hier
auf der Torte Austritt das habe ich
jetzt hier schon zweimal gemacht das
tritt nämlich immer wieder Saft aus
daher könnt ihr das auch ganz gut noch
mal aufsaugen und jetzt kommen die
Mandarine einfach nur auf die Torten
Oberfläche dann wird das Ganze
versiegelt mit dem Bus und dann müsst
ihr die Torte für eine Stunde in den
Kühlschrank wandern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit dem einzig wahren Hamza tasty mit
haben sie und haben sie immer gnadenlos
ehrlich das ist halt so ein Kuchen ich
finde damit kann man bei Familie Punkten
ob jung oder alt
ne aber es ist so aber ganz ehrlich egal
hauptsächlich schmeckt
sehr zart
sehr locker leicht also fruchtig genau
mein Name ist es wirklich nicht gegessen
wie süß ist auch perfekt muss ich sagen
nicht so süß aber auch nicht zu wenig
süß ach ja
zu essen
aber wir verteilen natürlich auch
fleißig viele Fragen immer wo gehen die
Stücke verteilen wirklich 30 wir haben
ja auch im Bekanntenkreis Menschen um
uns
herum mein Kanal links getan hast und
dann sehen wir beim nächsten Video
tschüss
[Musik]